This one says what 2020 has Pata.
That not everyone should make sourdough.
Hi, I'm Natasha Lucero.
I'm Rachel Brosnahan.
And we're here with wired to answer the most Googled questions about 2020.
I'm scared. Okay. Let's do this.
The 2020 world series count. Is that basketball?
Yes.
Then it should count hashtag sports,
which 2020 NFL teams are undefeated. You know,
what's interesting is NFL stands for not for Lazaro.
Giants. That was my high school. Mascot.
Is 20,
20 a LA Nina year without a hurricane or a sports team.
I don't know. Let's go with yes. Yes, definitely.
Our 2020 election results. Final. Yes. Yes.
That guy lost.
We don't have to have his voice echoing through our homes anymore.
How 2020 changed the world? I'm all.
For keeping the personal bubble. Post.
2020.
I personally love telling people to back the away from me.
Like whenever they come close.
You can't cancel digital plans. It's so much harder to cancel virtual.
You can't cancel cocktail hour. Cause everyone's like, what the are you doing?
You're just in your house.
And virtual plans are like 50% worse than real plans.
Only 50, 70.
77.
Where 2020 Superbowl the Tasha where?
Well, let me take a guess.
And I'm just going to guess a place that I would like to go, um, Montenegro.
Okay. Yeah. Take me to the Superbowl baby.
Okay. How 20, 20 M L B playoffs work.
I don't even know what this is. I'm not even like trying to be funny,
like M L B. Do you have any idea? I do.
I actually know major league baseball. This is baseball. That one.
I know they work, um, in a bubble,
everyone doesn't get to slap each other on the this year,
no slapping in this year's playoff.
Will 2020 go down in history. Interesting. People are Googling that.
We'll go down somewhere.
Next question has 2020 had the most hurricanes.
Yeah. Yeah. Inside and outside of the home.
It has felt like hurricane season for about a year is 20,
20 a leap year. Um, Hmm.
If you mean leap off of a cliff into a fire pit of
hell, then yes. I would say it's a good leap. Here is 20,
20 the year of the rat.
I mean, it's kind of a year of Rudy Giuliani. So.
Is that his nickname? That's a perfect nickname for him.
2020 Pennies worth anything.
A 1 cent is my understanding.
Did 2020 via amaze have an audience. Now I actually know what that is.
And I do know that their audience was a bunch of beautiful gen Z
cutouts. Ah, smart. I mean, I don't know. I'm just guessing.
Does 2020 have 53 weeks.
I feel like 2020 has 103 weeks.
Yeah. It feels like it's been like 6,000 days has 20,
20 been the worst year in history. You know.
This one's interesting. There have been some pretty gnarly years.
It's not a great year in history.
I would say 2017 when my comedy central show another period was canceled was
definitely worse. So no.
Who is 2020 world series MVP.
Natasha Ligero no, I thought Claire, uh,
performance was very understated, but uh,
Olivia Coleman was the winner did 20,
20 start a new decade. I feel like.
This is a trick question that would be on, are you smarter than a fifth grader?
And we would not be.
I went to public school, so I'm not really sure,
but it does feel that it started a new decade. Yeah.
The 2020 skip Easter. Uh,
I converted to Judaism just so I don't have to answer stuff like this.
I'm going to go with yes.
Although I did see the Easter bunny in times square. So maybe not.
Who is 2020 M B a M V
P uh, AOC where.
2020 World series played, um,
in our living rooms. No.
Yes. Good answer. Thank you. How many days in 2020,
I actually know this one. It's 600,050.
2020. Have the highest voter turnout.
Yes. Thank you. Young people. Thank you, black women.
Thank you. Activists on the ground who got people out to vote? Yes.
Can 2020 be over already so.
Soon. So, so soon.
Sounds like a 14 year old type this in what best meme of
2020.
I loved the fly.
The internet was that it's prime with Mike Pence's fly.
God sent that fly to Mike Penn.
2020. Would you rather.
Would you rather lick a seat on the
subway or touch an elevator button in time.
Square? Oh, I would definitely touch an elevator button really.
I dunno. I feel like they cleaned the subway a lot,
which 2020 Corvette is the fastest.
Who's buying a Corvette in 2028.
My husband bought like a Nightrider Corvette from the eighties. Um,
and he had it parked in our garage for about eight months and then I
made him sell it. So not yours, not your Corvette did 20,
20 AP exams matter.
I don't think they should have to matter this year.
How do you learn AP stuff on zoom?
Cancel AP exams 2020.
It was 2020.
The hottest year on record fire season was I think the worst on record.
So I don't know if that also translates into the hottest year on record,
but I would assume so because fire equals hot hottest in the bedroom.
Rachel, um, has the pandemic made you pretty horny?
Listen to Dasha. That is, uh, uh.
What's 2020 mentioned in back to the future. Good question.
I'm going to say yes. Yes.
I need 20. Should I buy a house? If you can, will.
2020 Be a cold winter. Oh.
I hope not. That's just me at the end of this year.
Moved to LA. It's nice here. It's always 75. And then when the, um, fire start,
I actually don't know how to help you should 2020 be declared a zero
year. Yes.
Yes it should. What? 2020 looks.
It looks like an old bar. Hag. Who's been, you know,
he's at the bar at like four 30 and she just fell off of her chair
with a lit cigarette. And people are just like walking on top of her.
And it's just a mess. Was 20, 20 a recession.
Not only was there a recession,
there was also a little thing we like to call a pandemic. A global pandemic.
2020 Was out here doing all the things.
When 2020 taxes due April 15th dogs.
I say dog now does.
The 20, 20 Rav four episode.
I live in New York. I wouldn't.
No, my dad actually bought one of these and yes, that's one of the appeals.
Like it's like a Jeep that has like the top off, but he lives in Florida.
So how.
2020 Started.
How it ended?
Well, 20, 20 coins be worth more. Listen, we're becoming digital.
We're all going to get chipped. There's not going to be coins soon.
No coins are really worth anything.
Let's save them just in case. Cause it could be like beanie babies.
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope this was inspiring. I feel like, um,
once we got through all the sports questions, um,
Rachel and I were really able to help you guys out.
I feel like we had a lot to offer.